[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: EVEN SOME DEMOCRATS
STANDING UP AT THE END.
LET’S BRING IN THE EXCELLENT
PANEL OF ANALYSTS.
COREY LEWANDOWSKI, A MANAGER OF
THE TRUMP PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
AND THE COAUTHOR OF THE HUGE
BEST SELLER, "LET TRUMP BE
TRUMP."
PHILLY BRIGHTNESS, A FORMER --
AND CHARLIE HURT, AND BYRON
YORK, A REPORTER FOR THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
COREY, TO ME, THIS SEEMS LIKE
TRUMP WAS TURNING THE CORNER
FROM THE HARD CHARGING, STRONG,
BUT COULD BE A LITTLE DARK AT
TIMES, AND TONIGHT, IT WAS
OPTIMISM, THE SKY IS THE LIMIT,
WE CAN DO EVERYTHING FOR AMERICA
IF WE WORK HARD.
I SAW THAT TURN TONIGHT WHICH I
THINK IS IMPORTANT.
>> LOOK WHAT HE FOCUSED ON.
HE FOCUSED ON REMINDING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHERE WE WERE A
YEAR AGO, WHERE THE ECONOMY IT
WAS AND WHERE IT IS TODAY WITH
JOB CREATION, WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
FOR THE HISPANIC AND BLACK
COMMUNITY AT RECORD LOWS, WITH
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AT RECORD
HIGHS.
ALSO, HE REMINDED OUR COUNTRY
THAT WE STILL HAVE PROBLEMS.
MS-13 IS A PROBLEM AND WE HAVE
VICTIMS IN THE GALLERY THERE
WHOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WERE TAKEN
BY THESE HORRIBLE PEOPLE AND WE
HAVE TO DO BETTER.
HE TALKED ABOUT WHAT HE’S DONE
AS IT RELATES TO GETTING RID OF
ISIS.
98% OF THE TERRITORY THEY
COVERED IS NOW GONE.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
GENERATIONAL PROBLEM IS WHAT
BARACK OBAMA TOLD US.
A GENERATIONAL PROBLEM.
IN ONE YEAR, 98% OF THEIR
TERRITORY HAS BEEN TAKEN OVER.
A LOT LESS THAN A GENERATION.
IT WAS A VERY GOOD, POSITIVE,
FORWARD-LOOKING SPEECH.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT IT WAS A
ROBUST DEFENSE OF AMERICAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD A HARD TIME
STANDING AT CERTAIN PARTS, WHICH
I THOUGHT WAS ODD WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT.
UNBELIEVABLE LOW.
AND YOU CAN’T GET DEMOCRATS
STANDING FOR THAT?
I MEAN, TO ME, THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU ARE CHEERING AGAINST
PROGRESS.
AND THAT IS WHY I THINK THIS NEW
POLL THAT CAME OUT TONIGHT IS
GOING TO FOR THE DEMOCRATS
UPSIDE DOWN.
97%, ACCORDING TO THE CBS POLL
THAT CAME OUT AFTER THE SPEECH
OF REPUBLICANS RATED AS WELL.
43% OF DEMOCRATS RATED GOOD.
OVERALL, 75-25 APPROVING OF
DRUMS SPEECH.
>> I THINK WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID TONIGHT WAS HE GAVE A
ADDRESS.
I DON’T MEAN THAT AS A
COMPLIMENT, I DON’T MEAN IT AS A
SNARK --
>> Laura: I DON’T THINK SO,
PHILIPPE.
>> I DON’T MEAN IT SNARKY.
THE MAN THAT COREY GOT TO THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION IS NOT THE
MAN WHO HAS DONE A
TRADITIONALLY.
HE IS NOT LEFT ANY STONE
UNTURNED, UP AND OUT, JUST
SMASHED.
THAT IS WORK FOR HIM.
THE STATE OF THE UNION SEEMED TO
BE THE LAST BASTION THAT HE
RESPECTED AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHAT I THINK THAT MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN THE BEST THING.
YOUR NUMBERS ASIDE, I THINK WHAT
YOU HAD TONIGHT WAS PROBABLY --
I WANT PRETEND TO UNDERSTAND THE
REPUBLICAN BASE -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS FLAT, IT
WAS NOT THE GUY THAT THEY
LOVED --
>> Laura: 75% OF REPUBLICANS.
>> NEVER IN THE HISTORY OF MAN
HAS SOMEONE SAID, REMEMBER LAST
WEEK WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS IN THE STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS?
THEY WANT NEXT WEEK.
I THINK THAT IT’S A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE’S A MAN WHO HAS TAKEN
EVERYTHING AND TURNED IT UPSIDE
DOWN AND MADE IT WORK FOR HIM.
HE LET THE STATE OF THE UNION GO
AS NORMAL AND WE ALL FORGET
ABOUT IT.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE CBS
POLL, WE’LL FORGET ABOUT IT.
HE COULD HAVE, AND SHOULD HAVE
JUST BEEN HIM BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT?
YOU GUYS THINK HE DID GREAT --
>> Laura: IF HE DID THAT,
PHILIPPE, YOU WOULD BE TRASHING
HIM!
HE WAS VITRIOLIC, HE WAS
ACERBIC, HE WAS ASCETIC, HE
DIDN’T BRING THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER --
>> YOU LOVE WHEN I GO TO MY
CRAFT FAIRS WITH MY FRIENDS AND
THE COCONUT JUICE IN MY AND WE
COMPLAIN ABOUT HIM WITH A
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
ARE YOU ONE OF THE 43% WHO LIKED
HIM BECAUSE I’M CHANGING MY
MIND?
PEOPLE WILL REMEMBER AND THAT IS
THE ONE ABOUT ALL AMERICANS ARE
DREAMERS.
I THINK THAT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT MESSAGE HE WAS TRYING
TO GET ACROSS.
MY GOODNESS, LOOKING BACK AT
WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO PREDICT
HOW HE WAS GOING TO DO THIS, OF
COURSE THE GUY, HE IS SUCH A
GREAT SHOWMAN, OF COURSE HE WILL
KNOCK IT OUT OF THE PARK IN
TERMS OF USING THESE PROPS,
THESE PEOPLE, THESE AMERICAN
CITIZENS THAT HE BRINGS IN.
REGULAR, ORDINARY AMERICANS WHO
DO EXTRAORDINARY THINGS, WHETHER
IT WAS THE NORTH KOREAN GUY WITH
CRUTCHES, WHICH WAS JUST
ABSOLUTE GUT PUNCH --
>> Laura: WE HAVE THAT CLIP.
I WANT TO SHOW THE CLIP.
WE’LL SHOW IT IN A MINUTE.
>> I THINK THAT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT, OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE MESSAGE HE’S TRYING
TO PUT AMERICANS ON NOTICE THAT
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE.
THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES AT
STAKE HERE.
THE COP WHO ADOPTED THE BABY
FROM THE METH MOTHER, AND THE
SOLDIER WHO SAVED HIS BUDDIES,
THESE WERE REALLY POWERFUL
STORIES.
WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT A
SHOWMAN LIKE THIS WOULD DO A
GOOD JOB.
>> Laura: WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING TO MY, BYRON, I WANT
TO HEAR FROM YOU.
WE JUST CAME OFF OF THE GRAMMY
AWARDS, THE CELEBRITY CULTURE,
SO INCREDIBLY ANTI-TRUMP AND
EVERYBODY FEELS GOOD BY TRASHING
TRUMP AND THAT’S FINE.
THEN HE BRINGS ON, WHICH OTHER
PRESIDENTS HAVE DONE, ORDINARY
HEROES.
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
OR MOTHERS OR FATHERS THAT HE
MENTIONED YOU JUST WORK HARD
EVERY DAY TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND ONCE YOU HAVE SADLY
BEEN BRUTALIZED BY GOVERNMENT
FAILURES TO ENFORCE OUR BORDER
AND I POINT TO THE MS-13 VICTIMS
IN LONG ISLAND ON THOSE TWO
FAMILIES -- OF COURSE, I STARTED
BAWLING -- I JUST COULDN’T HOLD
BACK THE TEARS.
WATCHING THOSE FAMILIES, YOU
DON’T OFTEN SEE THE VICTIMS OF
THAT TYPE OF CRIME.
YOU SEE A NEWSPAPER A SHORT
ARTICLE.
BYRON, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO SPEAK
TO THAT BECAUSE I THOUGHT FOR
WOMEN ESPECIALLY WATCHING
TONIGHT, I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
REALLY POWERFUL TESTAMENT.
>> YEAH, HE WAS VERY EFFECTIVE
IN USING THE PEOPLE THAT HE HAD
INVITED, AND HE USED ACTUALLY
THE TWO PARENTS THAT HAD LOST A
DAUGHTER TO MS-13.
HE USED IT BASICALLY TO
INTRODUCE HIS IMMIGRATION
SECTION, WHICH I’M SURE ENRAGED
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS.
ONE THING THAT WAS INTERESTING,
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD BEEN DOING
SOME HAD FAKES DURING THE DAY
ABOUT HOW THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY UNIFYING SPEECH.
AND IT REALLY WASN’T.
YOU COULD NOT HAVE A BETTER
EXAMPLE OF THE SAYING "ELECTIONS
HAVE CONSEQUENCES."
THE REASON DEMOCRATS WERE
SITTING ON THEIR HANDS DURING
ALL OF THIS IS BECAUSE IT WAS
CLEAR THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
DOING EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF
EVERYTHING THEY HAD HOPED TO DO
ON TAXES, ON IMMIGRATION, ON
FOREIGN POLICY, AND REGULATION,
AND JUDGES, ON EVERY SINGLE
THING.
THIS WAS A VERY, VERY REPUBLICAN
TRUMP SPEECH, WHICH IS WHY THE
REPUBLICANS WERE JUMPING UP
EVERY TEN SECONDS AND THE
DEMOCRATS REALLY, REALLY HAD
NOTHING TO CHEER.
>> HE WASN’T REPUBLICAN ENOUGH.
>> Laura: ALL OF THESE
FEATURES ARE TOO LONG.
I’M SORRY, THEY SHOULD ALL BE
CUT BY 20 MINUTES.
THEY COULD BE 15 MINUTES.
>> HE COULD HAVE.
>> Laura: IT’S NOT LIKE OBAMA
DIDN’T GO ON AND ON AND ON AND
ON.
THEY ARE ALL TOO LONG.
IT’S NOT A PARTISAN COMMENT,
PHILIPPE, BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
NICOLE WALLACE EARLIER TONIGHT,
COREY COME THIS ONE IS FOR YOU.
LET’S WATCH.
>> IT REVEALED DONALD TRUMP DEEP
AND ALMOST SAD OBSESSION WITH
BEING LIKED.
I MEAN, HE IS ALWAYS PERFORMING
FOR THE AUDIENCE WATCHING.
>> Laura: NO, BECAUSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE POLITICIANS AREN’T
INTERESTED IN PERFORMING.
I’M NOT SURE WHAT POLITICS SHE
HAS BEEN COVERING.
>> WHAT THE DUKE WILL NOT LIKE
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT THE
AMERICAN FLAG, THE 12-YEAR-OLD
BOY WHO WAS GOING BACK,
REMEMBERING THE SOLDIERS?
WAS AT THE PART SHE DID NOT
LIKE?
THAT YOU NOT LIKE THE PART THAT
WE MOVED THE CAPITAL AND
RECOGNIZED JERUSALEM?
WHICH PART DID NICOLE ACTUALLY
TAKE EXCEPTION WITH?
THERE IS NONE BECAUSE THE ANSWER
THAT DONALD TRUMP OUTLINED
TONIGHT IS THE MESSAGE THAT HE
TALKED ABOUT ON MY CAMPAIGN,
WHICH AS WE ARE GOING TO PUT
AMERICA FIRST.
I KNOW IT’S A NOVEL IDEA, I KNOW
THEY WOULD RATHER LIVE IN
ANOTHER COUNTRY, AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
SAY.
THEY PROMISED TO MOVE IF HE GOT
ELECTED.
GUESS WHAT, THEY ARE STILL ALL
HERE, THEY ARE STILL GETTING
RICHER AND I DON’T LOVE THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
NOW PROUD TO CALL AMERICA THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD AGAIN.
>> Laura: PART OF THIS BEACH
THAT I REFERENCED EARLIER,
PHILIPPE, WHERE THE DEMOCRATS,
JUST SO PALPABLY WEIRD, I’M
SORRY, THAT THEY DIDN’T REACT.
I WANT TO PLAY IT.
IT’S THE FIRST SOUND BITE ON OUR
SHEET.
LET’S WATCH.
>> I CALL UPON ALL OF US TO SET
ASIDE OUR DIFFERENCES, TO SEEK
OUT COMMON GROUND, AND TO SUMMON
THE UNITY WE NEED TO DELIVER FOR
THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS REALLY THE KEY.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ELECTED TO SERVE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
STANDS AT THE LOWEST RATE EVER
RECORDED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> AND HISPANIC-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT HAS ALSO REACHED
THE LOWEST LEVELS IN HISTORY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: PHILIPPE, THE
RESISTANCE IS, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUS
IN THOSE CLIPS.
THEY DON’T RECOGNIZE HIM AS A
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
WOULD YOU CAN SEE THAT?
IS NOT A LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL GIVE UP THE WHOLE IDEA
OF GOVERNING.
IT’S NOT A DEBATE ABOUT POLICY,
ABOUT, IF YOU CLICK THE TAX CUT
THIS WAY, WE WOULD SEE .7% MORE
GDP IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
THEY HAVE DISPENSE WITH ALL OF
THAT.
THEY ARE JUST NOT GOING TO
GOVERN WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
THAT IS MY SENSE WHEN I WATCH
THAT.
>> WOULD YOU RATHER THEY EXPRESS
THEIR DISAPPOINTMENT WITH THE
WAY SOME REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
DID IN 2009 BY GETTING UP AND
YELLING "YOU LIE"?
>> Laura: YOU BEEN ONE PERSON.
>> IF ONE PERSON SAID THAT, WE
WOULD HAVE AN 18 HOUR SPECIAL
EDITION OF "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
>> Laura: THE ENTIRE
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
SITTING DOWN FOR THE LOWEST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN EMPLOYMENT IN
RECORDED HISTORY.
I CAN SEE NOT LIKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT WHY WOULDN’T
THAT BE SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
APPLAUD?
MY POINT TO YOU IS THEY ARE NOT
AFRAID OF HIM FAILING.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF HIM
SUCCEEDING.
THAT MEANS HIS POPULISM HELPS
ALL PEOPLE.
>> I WILL GO ON THE LIMITS OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
HAS A BETTER INSIGHT INTO WHAT
IS BEST FOR BLACKS --
>> Laura: OH, REALLY?
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT THINK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN GOOD
FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
I DON’T THINK THAT THEY ARE
SITTING ON THEIR HANDS, AS YOU
CALLED IT, TO MAKE SOME KIND OF
POINT DESPITE THE NOSE ON THEIR
FACE.
IT DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE.
SENSE.
>> Laura: CHARLIE?
>> I HAVE A HARD TIME THINKING
THAT, THE WHOLE NOTION,
POLITICIANS, ALL POLITICIANS DO
THIS BUT DEMOCRATS DO IT WORSE
THAN REPUBLICANS ABOUT DIVIDING
PEOPLE IN RACE AND COLOR AND ALL
THAT KIND OF STUFF.
JOBS FOR EVERYBODY IS GOOD,
WHETHER YOU ARE BLACK OR WHITE
OR HISPANIC OR WHATEVER.
UNEMPLOYMENT DROPPING IS A GOOD
THING, AND I THINK IT IS KIND OF
A PETTY THING TO HAVE THESE GUYS
SITTING ON THEIR HANDS AND
SAYING -- IN THE END, IT DOESN’T
MATTER.
I WAS SURPRISED THERE WEREN’T
MORE INTERRUPTIONS.
TRUMP THROUGHOUT -- AND HE DID
THIS THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN,
IT’S WHY HE WON, AND HE DID IT
TONIGHT, HE CAME BACK TO IT AT
THE END, HE SAID THAT ABOVE ALL
AND THIS CAPITAL, THE CITY COME
OF THIS NATION, BELONGS TO THEM.
IT IS STRANGE THAT THIS IS STILL
A RADICAL IDEA AROUND HERE BUT
IT IS.
IT IS WHY PEOPLE LIKE HIM, AND
IT IS WHY PEOPLE HERE DON’T GET
WHY PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
>> Laura: BYRON, RETURNING
PEOPLE TO THE POWER, THAT WAS A
THEME DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
COMBATIVE DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
I’VE BEEN SAYING FOR SOME TIME,
I KNOW OTHERS HAVE WRITTEN IT,
WE NEEDED TRUMP TO TAKE THAT
TURN TO THE MORE OPTIMISTIC.
AND I THINK TONIGHT, AND I COULD
PICK OUT A SEVEN OR EIGHT POINTS
IN THE SPEECH WHERE YOU REALLY
STARTED TO SEE, WE ARE FOCUSING
ON THE PRIZE IS FOR EVERYBODY.
THIS IS A LAND OF RATE IF AN
OPPORTUNITY AND IF YOU WORK HARD
AND PLAY BY THE RULES, YOU WILL
GET AHEAD.
I THOUGHT IT WAS HIGH TIME THAT
HE MADE THAT TURN AND THAT IS
WHERE YOU MIGHT START SEEING
THOSE NUMBERS GO UP.
YOU ARE ALREADY STARTING TO SEE
THEM GO UP, 43% APPROVAL, HAS
NUMBERS ON THE ECONOMY ARE NOW
FLIPPED UP THE RIGHT WAY
ACCORDING TO THE
REALCLEARPOLITICS AVERAGE, THAT
IS GOOD STUFF FOR HIM.
>> YOU’RE RIGHT, IT IS TIME FOR
HIM TO MAKE THAT TURN.
IT’S INTERESTING, WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOW UNHAPPY AND
SOUR THE DEMOCRATS LOOKED DURING
THIS WHOLE THING.
LET’S LOOK AT THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY SEEM LIKE A PRETTY HAPPY
GROUP, VERY, VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE PRESIDENT.
EARLIER IN THE DAY,
MITCH McCONNELL SAID 2017 WAS
THE BEST YEAR FOR A CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLE SINCE HAD BEEN IN
CONGRESS.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE CBS POLL
OF NEAR UNANIMOUS REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS.
I THINK THAT THIS SPEECH WAS
ALSO VERY GOOD FOR SOLIDIFYING
REPUBLICANS SUPPORT.
HE HAD IT ON THE HILL BUT IT IS
ALWAYS AT BETTER TO HAVE MORE.
AS YOU LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
AND HAPPINESS, LOOK AT THE
REPUBLICAN UNITY IN RESPONSE.
>> Laura: THE REPUBLICANS WERE
MISERABLE FOR YEARS AND YEARS